all right folks we have some new
spoilers today I promised you guys that
I would keep you all up to date no
matter what news came out and I just got
home from work so let's sink our teeth
into these and do some major speculation
also I need you guys to stay to the very
end of this video there's something fun
I want to do and the winner will get a
shirt just like this in your size so
stay till the end to find out how you
can win that now let's begin
in my last spoiler video I reported that
the Game of Thrones production team has
arrived in Iceland to continue filming
scenes for its seventh season and
whenever they have filmed in Iceland
before those icy landscapes were used
for scenes that are north of the wall
indie scenes are going to be no
different they will be used for a scene
that takes place beyond the wall and
according to the plot leaked there will
be one action-packed scene north of the
wall next season Jon Snow
tormund Giantsbane Jorah Mormont beric
Dondarrion Thoris of mere the hound and
Gendry will all travel together during
episode six in Alan Taylor he's going to
be the one that's directing episode six
which is when the leak said this would
take place and how on Taylor has
actually been spotted in Northern
Ireland with some of this cast so that
just kind of adds another little piece
of information that helps us connect all
these dots these characters go north of
the wall in search of a light so John
can capture it and take itself to prove
to everyone in Westeros that there is a
threat that they all need to come
together for and focus on after they
secure the white they get ambushed by
the night king and hundreds of whites
then Daenerys shows up with her dragons
and is able to save everyone but John
who was surrounded on a frozen lake
during this the night King kills a
dragon and turns it into an ice dragon
and right when John is about to be
killed his uncle Benjen shows up and
sacrifices himself to save John so what
information do we have that helps
confirm that this is actually going to
take place well we have a frozen lake
they have casted 300 people that are
going to be used as whites John and all
these characters have been spotted near
the set and John has actually been
spotted filming his scene on this set
and he has dressed in what appears to be
wildling clothes considering the
wildlings lived north of the wall in
constant freezing temperatures they
probably would have the best clothes to
wear that are built for a mission like
this which leads us to the newest
spoilers now that they are filming in
Iceland which is always used for seeing
the north of the wall have any more of
these characters showing up that are
supposed to be in a scene north of the
wall yes yes there has
Jon Snow arrived the other day and it
was reported that Jorah Mormont was in
town too then Gendry and Thoris of Mir
arrived which helps confirm this scene
then today it can finally be confirmed
Jorah Mormont will be with them north of
the wall he did arrive in Iceland today
and a lucky fan actually stumbled across
the set as they were filming a scene and
if you zoom in on this photo you can
actually see that they all are wearing
wildling type coats just like Jon had on
during the frozen lake scene so this all
definitely matches up but there is
something interesting about this photo
the leek says they're going to be six
people with Jon Snow as they travel
north of the wall but when I look
closely at this photo there are actually
eight characters here dressed in the
same type of coats so who could this
extra character be could it be Davos or
could benjin have met up with them
before the battle even though the league
says benjin saves Jon when he is alone
could it have been wrong a little bit
and this may be benjin with them or
could Phelan have went after Jon
threatened him on the beach I didn't see
Theon near the boat when they were
getting ready to leave but I guess you
would never really know or could it be
the new Lord Commander or the new first
ranger of the Nights Watch or could
barrack and Thoros have brought a
different Brotherhood without banners
remember with them I actually have no
idea
but what I want to do is I want to see
which one of you can correctly predict
who this 8th character is going to be
with them north of the wall but pay
attention here you can only pick one
character so don't type in a bunch of
different people's names or else it's
not going to count because anyone can do
that
so just pick one person and that's going
to be your answer
leave your prediction in the comments
and the first person to leave the
correct answer is going to win this
t-shirt but you guys got to remember you
have to be patient because we may have
to wait a while before someone actually
gets a photo of this person or we might
actually find out tomorrow you just
never really know what these spoilers
but as soon as this mystery character is
revealed I will make the spoiler video
about it and announce whoever left the
comment with the right guess first so
good luck guys and also if you win
please send me a photo of you with the
shirt that way I can add it in the very
next photo after you receive the shirt
so thank you guys and I will see you in
the comments bye